what is your view on sex what do you
what do you think
makes sex such a fascinating topic so
many people seem
focused on it it feels so good
all right phillip yes phillip uh where'd
you grow up where you from originally
i'm originally from detroit and tell me
about your childhood you had both your
parents when you were a kid
yeah lived with my parents and my
grandparents my mom's parents
uh and my two brothers all in the same
house all seven of us and how would you
describe your childhood
um arizona middle class middle lower
class
you know things were tough in the auto
industry with where my father worked
which is why we lived at my grandparents
house
but there was love and there was
it allowed me the opportunity to
explore being from detroit that's the
biggest like a city it was back at the
time
so being around people that were not my
familiar allowed me to
learn to grow and appreciate things that
are not me that someone's not afraid of
trying something
new and that led to itself in many
different ways
um what kind of stuff did you get into
i mean like i was always adventurous so
i would always like take little trips
solo like i'd um one time
played a hooky from sixth grade eighth
grade
and went to go see opening day of the
detroit tigers um
so i took the bus down there and to rope
the
radio station that was giving away free
tickets
uh if you were the first hundred one
people in line or something like that
and um so i wrote rip rocks and i had
that
and i had a beer with this young couple
that was the first couple in line i was
number three in line to get the tickets
and yeah and then that was the first
time i got drunk without
being around my family that was eighth
grade yeah
that was fun um but that led to itself
in many different ways um
the adventurous side that is
especially when it
came time to you know
maturity uh puberty
and i was stupid me did not know
was i gay was i straight whatever
and so i told myself so before you start
high school
you better figure it out because i
didn't want to have any
embarrassing issues happen during school
you know
i was just paranoid so what do i do
as a 14 year old i responded to personal
ads that were in the newspaper um
and i hit up like one of i think like
every race because then
it was like who would be interested in
me and in
all my letters to these guys i was
upfront i was honest i'm like hey i'm 14
years old
i know that's illegal i'm sure you would
not be interested
but i need to find out if
i'm gay and i ask for you
to please spend a day with me
see what happens and maybe
get it in both holes there was one
response that i got
from a 27 year old black man
who turned up only lived like a couple
miles away from where i did
and so he arranged to meet me
and we met went back to his house
where he lived with his father but we
were up in the attic so we
my father couldn't hear us and for about
you know three four hours we did a lot
of
talking and watching a movie and
getting taken care of
and that made me realize
yeah i'm gay not only am i gay i like
sex
and i really like sex i love in me
um
and so i
was not i said not as
frequent having sex but you know maybe
once every other month or something like
that
after that incident summer of 88
and um
then i guess what really took off was
when i got my first job right the week
after i turned 16
working at kmart and i mean this is
in the hood so i'm
working on as you see i'm the bigger
person
men's bigger behind and
you know who likes the big butts and
cannot lie
that's when i realized that there was an
appreciation for
me and was hit on frequently
by black men
which just made me all the more
appreciative in
wanting to reciprocate that appreciation
for them
which i did find absolutely
and yeah i was picked up a lot
and where did that lead you well i'm
there this is at what age this is 16. uh
yeah at 16 with my first job um
there were a couple guys that came into
this um
to the kmart and i was a car
care collector it was one of my many
jobs there said be out in the parking
lot
picking up things and
yeah i guess my little dirty mind was
trying to get with people
and um i'd like follow solo guys you
know single guys that are going out to
the car like excuse me excuse me sir
um you look familiar are you uh in
movies
and they'd be oh maybe i'm not but i
mean like um
adult movies
with men in them only and
a couple of them got embarrassed or you
know who got offended
a couple were played off but then that
actually worked a couple of times
where one guy that would be
mr roderick i'll tell you about my
master later but
roderick he was like um well i'm not but
you want to make one with me
and this is like 1990 at this time and
there was i technology was not it was
nowadays so he had a camera though
but that was just his little pickup line
but he was following my pickup line
and he was proven on me um
he was like okay fine why don't you get
this
entertainment center that i want you
know once you have to assemble yourself
and since you get an employee discount
you hook it up
you buy it for yourself but then come on
over to my place
after work you know i so i did that
and proceeded to um
get into a two-year master slave
connection
with mr roderick where
i was introduced to a whole different
spectrum of kink uh so 16
17 18 years old until i went to college
i was
master roderick's play toy
preview best republican play toy
but he had a lot of uh yeah that was fun
um with master roderick he liked
leather scene so it was very macho and
[ __ ]
and i'm not the most macho but you know
i'm not the most feminine either
but like a pisces i go with the flow i
guess
and what master roderick taught me was
that
i'm willing to do whatever it takes to
satisfy
the alpha dominant man
with a big d and do what it takes
and that's the reason why probably my
grades you know like was really
brilliant to ninth grade tenth grade you
know slowly with you know
my grade point average went down and
then
went to college in the whitest part of
bum [ __ ] indiana
and it just seemed like time stopped
in terms of freakiness but that was okay
because i was trying to get a degree and
all that stuff
but that didn't pan up so well
mostly because of them my my libido took
over so i was trying to find
guys in college rather than trying to
you know study
i drop out i load her around
bump [ __ ] indiana for another year or so
move back to detroit
and now at this point we're in the 98 99
some 23 24 and
there's no restraining me i mean like i
would walk three miles to the nearest
gay bar
um because i didn't have a car
um there was no transportation that went
that way so
i would do that and proceed to get drunk
and
get hit on and do my own hitting on
people
guys um
then i got a job in downtown detroit
and that made it even worse because now
i'm in the core center public
transportation runs 24 hours if i wanted
to go anywhere
and there was a few bars i would like to
go to and
where my success rate was you know much
better than average
um and i
would do that um and at that point
that's when i realized that i was a sex
addict
because i mean as soon as i would be
finished
you know when seeing the guy out the
door immediately i'm like okay who's
next
how can i get the next dick in me
um
there was always various levels of
things that i did like i said with
thanks to master roderick
um there was
um he had me
entertain him and a buddy of his
and a couple of times two buddies of his
some having to satisfy
two big black sticks at one source three
big black dicks at once
was pretty fun for you know someone
in his you know late teens early 20s
um but it seems like that set off a
beast in me
where i wouldn't even have to
go to a bar i would be slumming around
downtown detroit looking in the back
alleys
picking up homeless men picking up
crackheads
um having them pick up me there was one
guy who was really interested in me
because he really liked big butts
and his name hand to god i remember him
seeing his license
michael jackson um and this guy was
very slender slim my height
black guy and
um i was [ __ ]
uh [ __ ] trade for him
that was fun then there was
oh gosh i'm so embarrassed by all this
but it was fun i just
i love sex and sex overpowered me
um i love detroit
and moved to phoenix to follow my family
because you know they're getting older
in years and my job went south
and i try to hand out a relationship a
nice
strand and not straight but a vanilla
gay relationship um it's a wonderful guy
with a beautiful
heart but did not have the libido that i
was
trained to serve and so
while dating him for over that six year
period
i fooled around a lot and that's where
master
curtis comes in the second
man that i submitted to
master curtis really liked
me as a femme a female and
demanded that i
get as female as possible if
i was going to have the dick again
because he gave it to me one time and it
was amazing and he was not go home and
just
he did it right
and basically trained me to feminize me
or at least bring up the female side of
me that's the reason why you've seen the
nails
um and i can do that as a result
that's where i do
my free time whatever must be done
that pleases the man
it feels like a lost identity sometimes
because i've had guys say that oh if you
can be
femme and you're not masculine or if
you're masculine sometimes that means
you're not a true femme
so i mean the ones that are sticking the
muds like the what they're certain type
um you know i'm canceled out but that
sucks but i mean it's just because
i'm willing to submit obey
and i like that and that's where i'm at
right now
i mean all my personal ads that i have
on various
chat sites and social different places
it's like yeah um i'm a freak
and i'd get to know me and
i've got some guys that there's one guy
especially right now
he lives in new york city i mean he was
considering moving up this way
as of our last talk he's saying hey why
don't you move here to new york
and it's everything i wanted which is
a
tpe contract if tpe is an
acronym in the bdsm world for total
power exchange
where i basically submit everything
to the man and as long as he looks out
for me and takes care of my needs and
whatnot
then he can own me i like that
and this guy mr ant
in new york city it's really weird
because as we've been chatting the last
two weeks only we've been um
communicating
it's amazing that our freak levels are
the same everything is
like two peas in a pod the only
difference is that he's a black guy
who's a top and i'm a white guy who's
bottom end but everything else
seems like it's in a perfect sink so i
can't wait to meet him i'd love him to
come here because i don't like cold
weather
[Laughter]
i've got tired of it but i'm
happy for whatever happens as long as
that's the right one we'll find out i
guess
are you ever worried about diseases oh
yeah
definitely because i would refuse to um
have sex without a condom for many many
years
but not with prep you know the whole
idea of
taking a pill and not contracting
anything
is a wonderful thing and that's where
the love of
you know the baby batter came in
once that realized that priority is
available
oh yeah what product is this what
product is this oh prep the uh um
a pill that you can take that prevents
transmission of hiv
is that right yeah i'm i'm naive here
okay yeah
so so your attraction to
sex has it has it made your the quality
of your life better or has it been a
problem
oh both i mean um it has been better in
the fact that
when you work in a
kinky uh sm lifestyle
you can let go some of your hang-ups you
know because
you do a lot of embarrassing [ __ ] not
not [ __ ] per se i mean there was one guy
that did but that was another
that's a different story that i don't
like getting into
um [ __ ] play is not necessarily my thing
but um having that experience at least
taught me that you know it wasn't the
end of the world and we'll deal with
things
something having sex has been
insightful in areas that don't relate to
sex
in what way um and well like um
dedication um
commitment to the purpose
that you have a goal if my goal is to
you know get
a sexy you know hung
man to make me his little like slip toy
that would make me happy but then having
that type of
drive for it helped me with my job that
i had
where i was working telephones for a
telephone customer service for a decade
because that was a pissed horrible job
but
it got me through how to
get to the end goal and now i'm not to
give up on it
um the negative things were
one time while at the gay bar of
downtown detroit
i'm hitting on different guys and i'm
having a success with like
three different guys that all want to
you know
either take me home with them or come to
my place
and it's now closing time and i got
these three guys like oh are you ready
to go you ready to go and these two guys
don't know each other
and they're not even aware of the fact
that i'm talking to the two others
and
what was embarrassing to
say you know to tell all three hey but
then
for a minute there they were all
interested in you know
coming by at the same time and having a
group thing with me
um man i'm good with groups like that
gangbangs
but um
because the tension
of them not knowing each other just made
me all crazy and
yeah that was a failure night because i
didn't get any of the three too bad
but i mean oh my god
do i say it i've had about 900
over 900 men sex
wise and over 800 were black
um
and it's not my fault though
um like when i moved to uh long beach
when i first moved here in
late 2012 early 2013
uh first of all i moved to long beach
because of a guy
i met online and we were feeling each
other because i mean he is exactly my
sight i was exactly his type
and so we were going to set it up as a
side piece arrangement because this guy
had a boyfriend
same name as me except maybe 40 years
older but we had a lot of similarities
but he lived out in the um
valley way in the valley far away and
would only see
this guy fred once every month or
something like that and so it's a very
loving but distant relationship
and fred being you know a big dick
brother
and means sex on the regular so when i
moved here
things were working out well in that
aspect
um he had a bad leg so he could not move
right so he could just lay down
basically and i
would give him oral for 40 plus days you
know
i was his every night oral [ __ ] toy
and i had a lot of fun with that and
there was a nice commitment there but
then
phil and fred get an argument or
something like that fred decides to
break up with phil supposedly
and wants to pursue something with me he
says
i'm not comfortable with that because i
don't want to be seen as a home record
because i because there was a love there
between phil and fred
and so i tell fred hey slow down i'm
sure the two of you will work it out
and they did as they were doing this
fred decides in his head that it was my
fault that i was trying to break them up
even though i'm submissive i'll be i do
not pry on people's toes
i've always been just the demure it was
uninstructed
and so fred
we were roommates um
because that fred was homeless and i did
not want fred to be homeless so i was
like hey let's get an apartment together
and we did and things were nice for that
first month but then
after this whole issue with his
boyfriend
they get back together and but decides
that it's my fault
i'm a homeworker i'm a bad evil person
and he proceeded to abuse me
physically mentally
financially and a couple times sexually
where like out of rage out of nowhere
as i'm laying down um on my stomach in
bed because after a fight i just ran
away and went to
the bedroom he follows me in there and
just comes up and bam
fists me and i mean like most of his
forums up in there
yeah it felt violated
for a minute or two because that was
just a shock and that was just part of
that why is this man such a psycho
followed by arousal
the whole
domination the whole um violent
rough aggressive sex that i had in
various forms prior to then
just took on a whole new level
but fred and i didn't [ __ ] around
because after that abuse
he treated me
like i guess like how cinderella was
treated by you know her [ __ ] sisters
like when they were just damning her
every single day there was no
appreciation of
you know her none with me by fred
i would have to bring home other guys
and
would while fred played you know out in
the other room
um and there was a okay arrangement
because i mean i was able to have guys
over and
this is where i was trying to get too
earlier sorry um
one of my [ __ ] buddies
within the first week of hooking up
he's like already over three times that
first week and he's like hey
can i bring a guy over next time
you know to share with me
you you know like okay i've done two on
one before i don't mind
i'm a great person at a spit roast you
know what spit roast is i don't okay
the spit roast is in cheek circles
imagine like a barbecue you know where
the pig is on this open spit
rotating and [ __ ] but you know get rid
of the flame
and you know get rid of anything
rotating and
insert me for the pig and insert
instead of the two big metal rod that
goes through just one big dick
shoved up its butt my butt another big
dick
down my throat and i will be servicing
both sticks at the same time with their
own dedicated hole
i don't know how freaky you wanted to
get but i mean
i've got amazing snapback for a booty
that has taken
massive sizes like
oh my god i got some good stuff sorry
um but yeah and then
when i snap back i'm good at the damn uh
spit roast and
i would just love to please the guys
that dante would bring over because
that was the role of being you know the
submissive obedient play toy of you know
the man supposedly
i'm not going to tell you that one top
story because that's
damaging bad but
it would be that dante would bring over
a different guy every single time he
came by
for a three month period three or four
nights a week
so when you add that up i mean that's
like 40 guys
you know that are
you know um new dicks
in me um
and
as a result oh yeah that's why i never
had double penetration i'm not gonna get
[ __ ] double [ __ ] in the ass by two
different dicks now i can do one in each
and then
a whole i can do double oral
because as you might see i got no teeth
long story on those but that's
irrelevant but
yeah my oral game went from a
10 out of 10 when i had teeth so i was
told
to just i mean amazing insanely good but
i mean
when you have hundreds of dick you learn
tricks and techniques and things you
pick up and
that's the nice thing is that whenever i
have sex nowadays
that first time with someone they are
blown away
i like that feeling
that's mine one that has been
groomed trained
owned by black men
and i don't mind um hence the reason why
a predominant number of hookups
i've been with men of color um
i like the freak in me
and i like the fact that i don't deny
the freaking me
um
yeah if we can
i just try and find a way now to
incorporate all my fun like the guy
in new york city like he's interested
in making videos with me adult ones you
let me post online which i already have
a couple of right now
those are just um me providing my oral
worship as i call it
you know going down on my fuckbud with
10 inches
all the way down and then another guy
that had the same
but it seems like always when i try to
get the filming of
more kinky stuff things fall apart i was
hoping secretly that you could help with
that
but um yeah i mean like if i could do
jordan night again
what i call jordan knight is my street
brother
um um
basically packed blocked me one night
when i got a motel room
because i was homeless i've been
homeless the last five years until last
year
i know i got an apartment down the
street but um
during that homeless period yeah i
developed
you know street family and my street
brother came to my motel room
and basically [ __ ] blocked me from you
know me having
you guys come over and whatnot he's like
he says to me i'll make it up for you
tomorrow i'll find a guy for you
woo-woo-woo
and that following night i had a hotel
room with me for that second night at a
different motel
and he brought a friend of his over
uh mr thai week and
tyreek was very fun
very muggle hung 11 inches and
my brother would watch my brother oh as
i call him
um was watching and he's like asking
tariq how is it how was my skills
and not to toot my own horn but i mean
oh damn good and i mean i already know
this because
when i can hear the guy's reaction and
feel the rage and his appreciation and
just
and that hookups become frequent [ __ ]
buddies
you know you're good so i mean
tariq says yeah this is damn good
my brother who i
was given rumors of him being mega home
also
um leaves my
line of sight as i'm you know my mind on
all fours on the bed
working on to reach my butt's up in the
air
and i feel a slap
and then i could tell that my brother
was
funk you know positioning himself on the
bed behind me oh my god my brother's
gonna [ __ ] me
my black brother and
yeah that missile went through
slowly all the way through and then
pump and he went like a jackhammer
and for a good two minutes
that's the way he likes the stroke thing
but i mean
i had my butt
beat up by him as i was getting head to
tariq's 11 inches
with my brother oh 12. that's 23 and
she's total number
dick of different answers might call
that night jordan night
because that was most memorable
and when most memorable type events like
that happen
i try to recreate it as frequently as
possible not necessarily with the same
guys because i would not want to touch
my brother like that
and but you know just have
high quality free time
and have it recorded and post it online
and try and get some money off it that's
fine be me because hey
i'm on social security disability i
don't have any income i mean besides you
know my monthly check and
when it's half the amount of money that
you were making
10 years ago you know that's next to
nothing
you've got to come up with a way to do
something
and my mind there's too many mental and
physical problems that
prevent proper work
what else is someone who's supposed to
do
i don't mind being a
freak under the table so where do you
think this behavior came from do you
think there's something in your
childhood or do you think it's just your
dna is
your wire this way well like i said i
suspected i was getting
things i wasn't i was an oddball in my
family and the fact that
and i was super intelligent um
gifted you know as they said and so
i mean they my parents tell me tried to
do their best you know giving me
chemistry sets
you know at 10 years old or something
like that and things
just i could not figure out
what would make me happy i was depressed
inside
i don't know it's just a middle child
syndrome gone haywire
or what but i
was a lost soul despite having good
grades and having a family that
stability i just
something didn't feel right and the
answer was i was gay
and when you're navigating this in the
late 80s early 90s
where you didn't have ellen
and there was no no
gay person of respectability i mean what
what
richard simmons who wasn't out there was
a flamboyant nightmare
i'm not that so how do i
navigate the world see if i grew up in
today's environment
i probably would have been a lot more
stable and not been as adventurous
you know in terms of sex and whatnot
and been a different person
but i mean going through the things i
did
i thought i has given me a lot of
strength
that i would have not had otherwise so
i'm happy about that
were you loved as a child do you think
yeah
i i would say yes um
my selfish side of me was that the fact
that my two brothers one older one
younger
are born on the same day six years apart
and it felt like big twin little twin
growing up you know when i'm the monkey
in the middle and
because i mean they had bigger birthdays
than mine
and this it felt like that there was
that overlooked thing
so i was fine with being that
independent side because i don't have to
follow the rules of the family
just figure out myself and make myself
happy
sex made me happy didn't expect that are
you happy today
oh yeah i am um
not with you know the exact position
where i'm at you know in the slum
apartment that i have currently but i'm
90
of where i want to be yeah when mr ant
comes to town where i meet him
hopefully it's a hundred percent because
oh wow i mean even though
like i said that this guy and i have
been talking and
having such a wonderful thing he is a
sex freak like me and
oh my god you should see some of the
texts that we have i don't have my phone
with me so you can't see them
but like one of the messages like i
expect
you to have your hole creamed
um by the time i get home so then i'll
have something to
you know pre-lubed for me
um i love raw sex
i love the feeling of the nut in me um
but it just fills me
yeah down below or swallowing the seed
um
and yeah i've done
threesomes foursomes
eight guys one time seven guys
twice i think um in the same
room at the same time um that
was pretty wild to know that i was able
to
sexually satisfy so many at once
are you the only white guy in the group
yes um
i'd say yes there was maybe one or two
occasions
of various um
group times where there was another
white guy there
um and the only way i would be
interested in
doing something with him is if i was
commanded to
uh i mean yeah commanded to that's what
master roderick did
master broderick also commanded me
before
he went to prison which is why and then
i wound up moving to college
within a month or two after that but i
hope that um
i'm to be a sex toy solely for men of
color
and hopefully black men only but
well not you know it's not
not possible to find a black man all the
damn time especially in bum [ __ ] indiana
but if at least was an arab man or a
latino hispanic um
then you know like a partial credit
would be viewed
and in detroit i lived in a very
arab uh
filled um heavy concentration number
and arab men are like black men in the
fact that
they like big butts and they're very
low-key um
i was at the casino downtown detroit um
on my lunch break and i'm wandering
around the slots oh because the casino's
right across the street from my job
and so i'm like looking at the different
slats and there was a guy
an arab man uh sitting alone in the
you know um one row of mangroves of the
uh
[ __ ] and he's just eyeing me and as i'm
coming
closer you can see this boom like super
big
tent that's popping you know through his
pants but not out to be graphic or
anything like that
and i turn around and motion with my
bullet
and look back and you know i see him
looking phantom
follow me we go to the bathroom one of
the bathrooms there and
it being a casino luxury place you know
individual stalls were
large and quiet enough where no one
could realize that there's two guys in
there at once or anything
and we fooled around and was like yeah
he's not like packing any
thing for you know fake in there that
was the real deal so i told him hey
after work i got to come back you know
go back to my job but
as soon as i get out i'm coming back and
he waited at the same slot machine and
he was great
um you ever been in love before
have you ever been a love before there
was that one guy i said that i fell for
that
was not my type physically because he
was built like a
linebacker um
but he had a cute smile and he liked the
way i looked
and i loved the fact that he had a
sincere heart
and that's why i tried to get into a
relationship with him and
had one for six years
there were ups and downs like i said
because even though he did not
um
get in the right spot because i mean he
had an average-sized
dick um my ex but there was a love there
but the need
for high quality
power [ __ ] um just
overwhelmed me so yeah i cheated
even though we were a couple
you know i knew that since we weren't
living together when i lived downtown
detroit you know he
he had a house that he stayed at with a
couple of friends of his
and i knew that they would fool around
on occasion
so i just told myself self you know
allow yourself to sing
and that's where then that super sweat
in me came by where
i would have five different guys
in a week every week like as i'm picking
up like i said the whole
how many times do you have sex in the
day
or what's the most you've had in a day
okay well i was at a bath house once i
had the one right down the street
that last time i was there i had
eight different guys in an eight-hour
period
and i would say closer to a six-hour
period um you know they were just like
rotating in and out of
the glory holes not that it was just
oral only
but that's where i was at with them
a couple did um come back to my room
because i had a little
tiny room that you can rent out um
then there was like i said the um
gangbang
that i had the eight guys that was one
time
um that was an overnight period
so orgasm how many orgasms would you
have in a day
well you know full well that
the orgasms amount that you had at 18 is
different
than today
so mine's been on a declining scale like
everyone else
every guy i imagine um
but as a bottom and concentrating
on the top i don't worry about having
any jack off orgasm having
the sensation of
the dick in me um
excites me when
i'm performing oral and
he unloads
in most cases i can swallow i don't have
a problem with that
um and then of course
that's the sign that he was satisfied so
therefore i'm satisfied
um that just goes in with that
submissive obedient
um just pleasing others personality that
i have
are you using drugs to do this or you
just naturally oh well i have a strong
leader i have
i do whatever the guy the man chose
so if he was a drug freed i would be on
drugs too
um i would otherwise if he didn't do
much like outside of
420 then it would be poppers that i
would do separately the
little vials that you get the sex shops
or
porno stores that when you sniff it
for me i don't know what it does but it
relaxes muscles uh then
and a big way where then i can take
i'm like a size dick because as i said i
got a
i've got a tight [ __ ] slit for a whole
despite the fact that it's been
beat down so many times it's amazing
that my snapback
goes back to where it looks like it's a
virgin [ __ ]
as i'm told by many of black men i mean
i can't see it myself and i don't know
i don't know what [ __ ] look like but so
they say these things
um but after my brother's night with
after jordan night
that was you know late night
mid-afternoon the following days i mean
but within 16 hours after that
i was [ __ ] again by a different black
guy
um and he was a modest
eight so he's clearly like four inches
smaller
than my brother but while
mr pharaoh is [ __ ] me he's like man
this is why i love [ __ ] you um you
just wrap around
my dick like a glove um and i'm thinking
myself
wow and if he knew that i had
a dick that's a almost twice his size
and i'm working me out within the last
20
24 hours he wouldn't believe it you know
because
pharaoh was loving it i loved it too
but i mean i don't think my snapchat
comes that fast all the time
i can't imagine that it would still be
as good now but
i mean last time i was banged out he i
had to like
pull my cheeks apart so that way he can
figure out how to get through i'm sorry
did i do anything
with with this okay good uh that
if he was enjoying it then um
yeah the last time i got banged out was
two weeks ago by a 20 year old
because thanks to mr dante's um
bringing over guys all the damn time
thing
he picked up the guy on the bus a train
as
going from l.a back to long beach and
brought him over
and the kid said he was 19
and like i said with
good guys that i had a good time with
well dante was
being the drama queen whatever i would
like hook up with him on the side the
other guy on the side
so i did that with the 18 or 20 year old
19 year old he only kept on changing it
because it was always 20
and then like after a month it's like oh
no i'm 19.
after a month no i'm 18.
and at that point i froze think to
myself is he gonna dare say
he's 17 or under because
that was amazing what he was doing
i did not pursue it
i but at this i got paranoid that
he would be reporting me or something
like that so i was like
you know what one more time and then
we're gonna have to pause
until i get verification from you i know
you are how old are you
i'm 46 right now yeah at that point that
was in 2013.
so 38 at the time and so
like look i was 14 when i lost you know
when i gave it up and
had it on a regular basis um before
turning 18. how would i begrudge someone
else
but be honest i was honest with my guys
and if he was up front if he was
underage and said like hey i'm only 17.
i'll be like okay guess what we're
working this out
fine you know we could have been a
wonderful [ __ ] [ __ ] but
you got to be honest for the core of
what makes sex good honesty but what
would you say is the most important
lesson you've learned in your life
time time will
sort out any crises any problems
just allow that time to happen don't
[ __ ] with time by you know trying to
rush into things
like the relationship with
that guy but i had the love
that because we're still friends to this
day the ex
uh the love that i had but that was best
not the right time for me to have tried
that i'm glad i did ultimately because
that was a wonderful friendship that was
formed but
take the time to do things right
like because you may not get a chance
again
and if you really care about something
give it your all what is your view on
sex what do you what do you think
makes sex such a fascinating topic so
many people seem
focused on it it feels so good
that you're having that
tabby to slot b type
feeling is one that
is not done you know to anybody
everybody
unless you're a straight up super mega
[ __ ] but
just the fact that it's intimate in a
way
it's a private personal thing just
between the two of you
so to speak where
if you're not doing anything stupid you
could make a very good time out of it
and that that is what feels good
something that is not done by
many others i like that independent
thing that i'm doing things of my own
that
make me happy but just
having my holes stretched out is very
fun
and it relaxes me
excellent well philip thank you so much
for
describing your fascinating life oh
that's fascinating
thank you very interesting sometimes but
yeah i didn't know where to go
because that's what sex is sex will
involve a lot of stuff that's freaky
geeky and you might have to explain
yourself